but there was 1 period that people ordered less
Uhm
it was the same for you
well it was super exciting that phase because uh
at some point
the moment came when the shops also had to close
yes and then we really decided as a brand
what we stand for
our strength is also that service to our partners
so and we knew
of course not that it would take that long
so we thought we are really going uh
talking to the uh with the shopkeepers
how can we help you with this pandemic
uh get through
uh we put out 2 × 1 camp
Support your locals
in that period
just to encourage people not to join us online
to shop because we saw that
immediately as soon as we close shops
uh we really saw that our online turnover went up